hey reject nation i'm greg alba i'm
journals we're gonna watch for mr.
crepes just an amazing channel crepes
crepes Avengers infinity for x-men Days
of Future past die all we watched the
Days of Future past trailer that we're
assuming this is mirroring in some
fashion before we do this couple of
things I want to mention one we are
going to Mexico from the 23rd to the
25th courtesy of Warner Brothers if
anything big drops we don't happen to
cover it
that is why secondly patron of the day
shout out that's gonna go out today to a
lovely woman I'm assuming lovely name
Victoria Huntley Victoria pledged to our
patreon page in July I've been trying to
message her to get a whole verse like
give her a proper shout out but she
hasn't gone back to me for some reason
why Victoria I love getting to know the
women who owe you Victoria now I'm her
name stands for victory and conquer and
her last name Huntley stands for hunter
and it could also mean would clearing
the combination of two old English words
apparently that's amazing I mean your
name victory conquer and hunter you just
sound like you're the ultimate badass
you're probably a very timid lady and
frightful like an axe-wielding Dexter
type just chopping up logs and you know
we don't know why because you're not
messaging suspect Victoria and now
you're stuck with this shoutout I'm sure
it will suffice thanks for being a part
of the page
marvel stud tens the extracts the heavy
toll
ours choices require the strongest wills
this is exactly how the
[Music]
I would love to watch them side-by-side
yeah
[Music]
to bring balance to the universe wipe
out half of Allah
Bryan Singer director usual suspects he
invades planets he wipes out half the
population
he said Loki the attack on New York
that's him
the Harrises been inside my head for six
years since they sent her army to New
York and now he's back do you know the
only one cursed with knowledge well the
curse is you
yeah
actually have something you read bad
we teach you nice man he really captured
the tone and style yeah well I feel like
the tone and style of the the Days of
Future past trailer really lends itself
really coalesce is nicely with infinity
or because I mean it's mashup of the
x-men universe to help for a bigger
cause I mean you have to work together
and Finn any war lends itself pretty
well today yeah yeah and the tones well
the tone of the Days of Future past
trailer and the tone of infinity war
kind of match each other I feel like you
pointed this out what we were watching
the x-men trailer like that movie is a
lot more fun the trailer let's on to
Karen's comedian you know you're gonna
give me the keys he car and some money
for gas or are you gonna wake up in the
hospital trust me I know how these
things play out oh because you're from
the future no because of these
[Music]
you and I are gonna be good friends you
just don't know what you I feel like
infinity ward is not quite as more fun
as any of the Dragons I feel like this
is actually really nice here in terms of
how he even structured the trailer its
structured exactly like the Days of
Future Passed trailer where the
beginning is setting up through you know
overlapping images of devastation people
looking devastated view looking
depressed people sharing dead a moment
some yeah a lot of like tense looks and
then you're teasing what's at stake with
the dialogue in terms of the emotional
factor and then after it said from the
Russo brothers director of this and this
kind of like how the Days of Future past
trailer did then they start getting into
so Mike what's the actual plot you know
okay and that's in the action gonna look
like like how they're explaining it and
when Wolverines like oh I go into the
body that it and then Mark Ruffalo
talking to the team yeah here's what's
going on kill Loki we need to do this
and yeah the patience isn't my strongest
suit from the original trailer that
originally cuts to him like screaming
and I patience isn't my strong suit
and Thor here and Thanos his grip
screaming in agony like right after
Ironman says his line
yeah our maddest country like the
Wolverine of this trailer I only curse
is you yeah I think that's the point you
to do with this is to look around an oak
a so this character is kind of the the
counterpart to that character and yeah
this guy's Professor Xavier this guy's
Wolverine you know after in the Thoreau
and then everyone starts like they could
do the montage is where it looks like
our heroes are definitely gonna lose
this yeah in the days of future past
communicates that vibe you have James
McAvoy in the Days of Future past
yeah exactly and then everybody they
replace that with star-lord here to
going on she's lying
tell me you didn't do it I guess
star-lord he doesn't want a future yeah
a lot of people get to Xavier there's a
lot more characters yeah any war trailer
you're dealing with all the characters
yes that of a select few x-men when we
did watch the Days of Future past
trailer I was thinking are there a shot
and if it any more that's gonna be able
to mirror the two week saviors but you
can't do that so I mean picking the
moment with Thanos and Gomorrah and the
soul stone is the best fitting one oh
yeah mood and dialogue yeah that does
fit and its own right in this mr.
crutches trailer I just I caught this
little moment is that actually in the
movie or black panther jumps up into
Thanos is grim really oh I guess I'm
it's when they're all attacking him at
the end
oh damn it was bailed this at the sh
Motown John what would that question of
you who jumps into Thanos grip in the
finale after they had the battle in
Wakanda and they're all going after him
one at a time it's in that scene when
Captain America is holding the glove who
jumps into Thanos his grip easily worded
question most of you are below Cinematic
Universe no black panthers jumps up o
only BP I should write the questions you
should you do critically communicate mr.
Crouch's just did it again this is
beautifully done
I feel like this guy should be working
for actual movie studios in the future
it's like cutting together zone trailer
it's gonna happen one of these days I
feel like cuz he's just really sharp it
like this is I feel like this is just
great trailer for infinity war yeah you
know you borrow the style and again I
feel like the styles do lend and both
movies have a certain element of hope
and the lack of hope at their core yeah
so as you know it's not like a huge
stretch or anything but I kind of
actually find this trend to be really
fun because you just get to see all the
different alternate universe trailers
and I thought this made a great trailer
for like even if I didn't know that this
had anything to do with being a
reference to the Days of Future past
trailer I just think this is a really
well-done ad yeah because the music
works so well with it too
the music works great yeah and just it
looks so intense and just the way they
recut it - I mean like I appreciate it
the style they went with for the
original Infinity Ward trailers but this
just makes it look so desperate and
intense it makes me wonder if there are
movie studios that kind of do that with
other movie trailers is there a trailer
can we do the exact structure imply it
to our movie would it work here you know
I wonder if the studio is that maybe
that's why they always use like similar
types of cover songs let's try to do
that oh dude I mean because because
trailers are such a cottage industry I
mean I gotta imagine that just between
the houses the ad houses the trailer
houses alone that cut these things have
to be keeping an eye on each other's
work taking notes and I wouldn't be at
all surprised I mean we all got the
Internet you know I'm sure some of these
dudes like sitting around a trailer park
I've seen a couple of these and a promo
gun it's not a bad idea
yeah congratulations again guys he has a
patreon page too so I would highly
recommend go checking that you guys
can't subscribe to mr. crepes just
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell lick it and hey
check us on patreon as well phone line
TV show reactions weekly Q&A is a music
video coverage we'd love to have you
become up a tragic to die